Newton please so what happens to fuse
the headshot increased directional
critical hit that's probably gonna kill
him anyway he says yes okay um Kepler
get the hell away from that thing put
that thing back where it came from also
help me now we could I'm actually gonna
reload I was gonna say we kids run and
gun him get up there to shoot the guy in
the face but that's not I don't know
that doesn't sound very survivable
Newton's gotta kill that's something
right
let's just trade out the perfectly big
good bit of cavalry had for that bit of
sacking um Kepler will never watch ok
cool guys don't look at explosions you
know he just he just walked away from
that okay um so frustrating Copernicus
is really an Astra doctor support role
from here just because he's so wounded
oh come on
oh we've already used on move okay I'm
not all oh my god whenever I talk about
scientists they die I'm not usually
confident about his chance of survival
just saying no please don't kill Kepler
please please I was gonna talk about him
next i shouldn'ta set that I didn't ask
you for that uh right come on please
please please please please please yes
okay this isn't stressful at all
especially when you're dealing with the
literally the world's worst sniper
hunker down um I'm worried about pushing
it with Hypatia on this side because one
there might be more aliens do fer if
there are she'll probably just kill them
anyway because she's type 8 [ __ ] oh I
can't move the camera I don't like like
it I can hear that I can't see come on
come on oh I had such high hopes you all
the time so he's been mind-controlled I
guess from this dude no there's another
one okay that cars going to explode
probably not of that much as much use
can we
come on hypatia come on come on come on
come on yes
I kind of want a running gun beside for
the ash net we could probably just move
here
that's where the dude is ok but if I do
that he is almost certainly dead so we
do we take a twenty six percent chance
FML do we run back like a coward or to
be running gun mmm Hypatia could be the
answer here can we get her to kill this
dude oh no she's already done it ok um
Kepler right mmm not really what I
wanted Newton
Oh
mm-hmm I don't like being in charge of
all these important people if you go
there you will die yeah ok let's just be
sensible if we put you on overwatch
Kepler or we could just take a shot now
mr. ah yoooo meant to be professional
soldiers con explode make the car expert
may the car explode yeah yes how do they
know damage him if that was me I'd be
dead right need some redeem yourself
actually can we if we push up with
Kepler right does that now mean that
Newton could see the other didn't oh
okay nevermind oh oh I didn't think that
through did I know I didn't okay sit
where's this other guy came from then
he's like over here somewhere we can't
quite run and gun
so much fire so much destruction need
ssin
now's your moment yes well and you
sounded reading easily okay that cars
already exploded so we can move
Copernicus up to there so now you can
see no right we'll hunker down here next
time we're running gun and shoot them in
the face unless i pay she just that's
our thing ah close enough she's so
trigger-happy hmm the original game was
a lot more I'm basic than this the right
run and gun
so let's run in here let's hope there's
no more aliens after this guy right in
the face how did you miss how did you
miss ninety-four percent chance and you
missed
Oh bulls um okay oh my god oh oh god
this doesn't look good right okay let's
consider our options here Newton is
useless as has always
can we you can rotate the camera can we
get Kepler to a point where he can take
a shot come on cap oh no everyone's just
run out of ammunition okay so i only
could kill any one of like three
different people no oh my god it's to
malign Simba simple as a knife right
take him out shoot him in the face
another day another successful operation
oh my god oh my god oh my heart okay no
one dies that literally amazing oh wow
lazy set lazy my art good God yo what is
it good for right that was a bullet we
got no just remember we want 200 bucks
from doing that
we may as well just become strippers and
gone to Vegas Newton yeah of course she
didn't get windows you didn't need it
bloody all I'd stop myself and Reese
wearing there and say I've got to save
that her okay most of us was a wounded
so okay we can we can get thirty percent
damage from all sources of the next full
turns or suppression target stuff same
penalty and cross yeah that's way better
okay Kepler through three more towels
covering fire sprinting um how do we use
you in the in that given that you're
going to be moving around I think I'm
going to make you sprint if we're using
you as our medic and Copernicus plus ten
percent crit chance for enemy in sight
or plus fight anything that makes you
more survivable because my god you took
a pounding good God and we got nice more
stuff panic in Austria is decreased by
one yeah and now we can build okay so
you could build a lab a power generator
or alien containment so do we already
have a lab where we do well let's ask
about
mm oh I should have done that [ __ ] oh
well that was that's reckless spending
unless think we get an adjacency bonus
so any but you also get and I'm hmm
let's not needing containment though
okay right uh that last mission oh my
god how we doing on research
experimental war for one day okay I wish
they gave you how many days you had
light in India PhD if they were like oh
you're gonna finish this in two days
time you can you know schedule around
it'd be great right what do we find out
from this foundry and Phoenix cannon and
if that's an x-men reference it probably
is okay foundry we can build things are
thorough research the weapon fragments
carapace honor hmm we actually haven't
had any trouble killing the aliens
recently and we are survivable so that's
true that's probably go for the plot the
main quest and built that Oh
right I like how our days are just spent
oh can we build something uh we've got
yeah that's fine okay we only need to
build as many vests and medic it's
actually getting use for the scores you
can just move them around all right
commander we're receiving a transmission
from the council 30 times up life is
undoing I still can't believe dr. Valen
expects our troops to try to bring one
of those things back here in one piece
much less alive oh the UK a politician
from the UK has once advocated
cooperation with aliens has now come
under attack oh I guess that's not Nigel
Farage them great so we're rescuing
we're actually rescuing a left-wing an
ultra left-wing politician that wants to
cooperate with the aliens that are
attacking us actually that's why not
left wing that's just stupid like I am
I'm left-wing myself and the UK does
have a lot of panic at the moment so all
right do we have anyone else
all the other scientists are currently
injured huh okay um right let's go in
and edits rookie kojima we're gonna make
you sorry at the Micra front Mary
Somerville now you might recognize
actually that all the girls so all the
women I wouldn't say all the boys that's
pretty sexist all the women that are
that bloody hairstyle the part of the
squad are actually also on the top
female scientists car game if you're not
aware of that then yep that's
affirmative then that a shed that's not
completely unlike her then this is
that's a car game of 32 women from
across all of history by which it
basically it stands about Hypatia right
back to the present day looking at the
contributions of women to science
because she can have a ponytail that's
quite nice okay and that was probably
about her hair color cult paddock Oh
loadouts
we did demonstrate last time that okay
yeah so um basically I've been cheating
and using all the women from that deck
of cards oh good god that's so I'm
really sorry my voice isn't loud enough
for this whole video by the way okay
where every landing the next deployment
that was not Manchester that was
definitely not Manchester on the map but
Manchester's like 200 miles further
north than where we landed okan mutant
yes come on get a kill check it out oh
what a shot Nathan I'll take it all back
I was really cool